[Musique]
la fondue au fromage traditionnel est un
plat réconfortant constitué de gruyère
des mentale ou de vacherin que l'on fait
fondre dans un caquelon en suisse on les
trempe des morceaux de pain ou des
morceaux de pommes de terre chez nous de
nombreuses marques attire notre
attention avec leurs emballages coloris
ça comptait le fromage assez générique
d'élite cp mentale des types derrière
des fromages assez bas de gamme c'est
somme toute des mélanges qui sont quand
même satisfaisant et notre amour de la
faune d'une date pas d'hier
rappelons nous de la publicité de la
faune du swiss night qui est en soi un
classique
il est à noter que presque toutes les
fondus sur le marché sont importés et
qu'elles sont confectionnés avec un seul
type de fromage mais plusieurs
fromageries québécoises propose aussi
des mélanges a fondu les beaux produits
même on a entre autres celui ci la
laiterie charlevoix la fondue de
l'isle-aux-grues les petites fromageries
sont mis à se sont mis à la tâche qu'ils
sont bien faire des bouts mélange a
fondu
si on y va 100% local on peut prendre
des mélanges
mais on peut aussi composer nos propres
fondu à partir de différents formats
en fait j'ai choisi des réussites super
simple vraiment facile à réaliser
complètement différente
la première recette en fait c'est
vraiment vraiment très très classique
j'ai choisi les reculs de charlevoix on
pourrait le comparer un petit peu un
jeune comptait donc avec ces cdd des
belles saveurs un peu un peu nous a cité
un peu du mal un peu fruité
c'est assez complexe et on a également
alfred le fermier qui va partager
certains étaient armés qui va avoir une
pointe de sel un petit peu plus
prononcée on va se rapprocher un peu
plus du site gruyère avec celui là donc
avec ces deux formations pour pouvoir
facilement faire une belle font du bien
construit il ya toutes sortes de
variantes qu'on peut faire honnêtement
les recettes de fondue sont infinies
simon suggère aussi d'autres fromages
entre autres chemins attelé victor et
berthold le gré des champs louis d'or le
frère chasseurs clos des roches ou pico
bas
mais en fait c'est tous des fromages qui
vont traîner fonctionner en fondu
j'aurais pu inventer du tour de récits
de fond du permis cela ce qui est
l'idéal quand on veut faire un mélange
c'est de ne pas dépasser trois types de
fromages différents
c'est ce qu'il faut prioriser les pas de
ferme des fromages des fromages qui ont
vieilli parce que on veut évidemment que
c'est du goût ont rappelé aux fromages
grossièrement et on les mélange je sens
que je me fais haïr par certains
puristes mais voilà je vais rajouter un
petit peu de véhicules parce que oui la
fécule ça facilite vraiment vraiment
travaillé lors d'une fondue puis ça va
vraiment faire en sorte que ça va les
formations s'assimiler avec plus de
facilité ça va beaucoup moins séparés
avant de commencer il est recommandé de
frotter l'intérieur du cat long avec une
gousse d'ail
question de goût bien sûr mais aussi
pour empêcher le fromage d'adhérer aux
parois je vais juste commencé par faire
chauffer mon rang moyennement à feu
moyen élevé on ajoute le liquide au fond
dans cette recette un vin blanc sec
convalescent un tout petit peu au fond
vraiment pas beaucoup on le porte à
ébullition jusqu'à ce qu'une petite
mousse se forment en parallèle on
chauffe aussi une petite quantité de 20
supplémentaire pour nous permettre d'en
ajouter au besoin qu'on va commencer
tranquillement et le vraiment au niveau
tranquillement on n'y voit pas une
grosse quantité la foule l'idéal le cds
est d'amener la fondue à peu près une
soixantaine de degré et risque est
important en fait à vendre acheter
d'autres fromages c'est de bien attendre
que le format choix parfaitement intégré
au liquide reste plus qu'à goûter donc
très important de toujours piqué à
travers la croûte une fourchette de
distanciation on vient enrober le tout
voilà ça c'est ma fourchette coville à
la route
voilà pour le tout on n'a pas de
concertiste et on goûte le vin en bois
de fromage
voilà ce qu'on veut
la deuxième proposition de ciment est
une fondue de style awards à la bière
ambrée fait de fromage cheddar de l'isle
aux grues
on fait ça avec sans forcément de
cheddar cette fois ci et on va rajouter
un petit peu de moutarde de dijon
également il est important de choisir
une bière avec peu d'amertume pour les
bières de microbrasseries recherché
lundi ce d'amertume ibu et prendre celle
avec un ibu de vin ou mois les armes se
concentre une fois que la mousse est
tombée on ajoute la moutarde de dijon
puis le fromage mais voilà une petite
poignée à la fois évidemment il avec le
cheddar
c'est magique c'est déjà presque le prix
on va avoir un beau brad aurait très
savoureux de goût stationnent à huy lê
sera nettement de vous dire c'est pas
mal de mes recettes préférées de fond
tout simple et la harga semences et
crémeux ça y est complètement enveloppé
sans laisser de filaments et ce c'est ce
qu'on va obtenir c'est vraiment déçu
mais à la veille tu me radical a bien
sûr j'aurais pas deviner non non j'ai
côté malté derrière un très bon
que dire sinon
[Musique]